this is from Breitbart it says after
eight seasons four sex change surgeries
quote unquote and countless hormone
treatments TLC's I am Jazz star Jazz
Jennings still doesn't feel right I
don't feel like me ever Jennings
revealed in a recent episode Jazz
Jennings was born a boy and declared
himself transgender at the age of five
confessed feelings of dissatisfaction to
his mother Jeanette I just want to feel
like myself all I want to be is happy
and feel like me I don't feel like me
ever
uh Jazz at an emotional exchange caught
on camera so this
reality show is still ongoing and Jazz
Jennings has been
um
quote unquote living as a girl
now for years
but isn't happy I think we have the clip
of that let's watch it so um are you
feeling like you wanted to start talking
about
are you okay I'm okay I'm gonna cry
you know I can't get out of my head I
know no listen
it just doesn't stop it's okay give me a
hug it's okay I know what you're going
through we've been there no way it still
doesn't stop now and I'm already going
back to negative but there's more you're
talking about yourself it gets harder
you're digging in in your it's making
you put a magnifying glass on what's
already difficult as it is
so this is hard for you I know and you
don't we don't want to push it I know
I'm the one doing it like I know you're
almost enemy
I feel kind of all over the place and
like my mind is very cluttered and not
clear and I really want to have that
Clarity I really want to understand
myself and be able to read my own soul
and what I want and it's just very
challenging and I think I'm kind of
breaking down a little bit and spiraling
into negativity
I just want to feel like myself like
that's it I don't care all I want is to
be happy and feel like me and I don't
feel like we've ever
uh okay so that's
actually in a really depressing and
terrible way it's it's a powerful clip
because of the words that he uses I
don't feel like myself ever I don't feel
like myself
now you hear from the abusive this this
mother I mean obviously all these
parents that Force this on the kids are
all evil but this woman in particular
you know it's different for her because
we've seen this has been we've seen this
documented she has documented herself
psychologically abusing and uh
brainwashing and conditioning her son to
believe himself to be a girl we've seen
this over the years
and uh so you can see just how
evil this woman is you know she says
I've been through it I know it no you
haven't
really you've been through that
your son is mutilated beyond recognition
and he's gone through with the whole
quote unquote sex change quote unquote
gender affirmation uh medical you know
these the whole catalog he's got
so you you know what that's like do you
lady no you don't you have no idea
no because you were able to go through
childhood and then early adulthood uh as
yourself
okay you didn't have this false identity
imposed on you
so you have no idea what that's like
and you never will know
I don't feel like myself you know that
is uh
that is
as direct as we're gonna hear certainly
as direct as as a TLC reality show will
allow us to hear
of a trans identified person saying this
is a mistake
and all of this was about all this
identifying as a girl getting the
surgeries and drugs it was all about uh
supposedly him living as his quote
unquote true self and even after all of
that says I don't feel like myself
because yourself has been robbed from
has been taken from you
and also keep in mind when you look at
that clip
you know we hear this discussion about
um regret after surgery regret after
transition that we hear stories of the D
transitioners
and we know that this is much more
common than what the powers that be will
tell us
but also remember that
the people
the transit fi people who are not in the
who don't who do not officially count in
the regret category or the D
transitioner category many of them
and I would say a vast majority of them
are in this kind of category
where they're not going to come out and
say I regret it it was a mistake but
it's very clear they're still unhappy
that's why suicidality is is you know
highest after transition uh still very
unhappy is still in deep despair
but what they also have
they they have an intense psychological
motivation themselves to not fully admit
to themselves that it was a mistake
because there's no turning back and so
if you admit that it was a mistake then
where you go from there
but they also have you know Jazz
Jennings
has his his mom
who's there and won't allow him
to consider the possibility of those may
be a mistake
because it was a mistake for him it
wasn't really his mistake it was her
mistake
it's not that jazz Jennings didn't make
a mistake because this happened to him
when he was a kid before he could
consent to it this is a mistake
and I say mistake in the sense that it
was the wrong thing to do not like it
was done accidentally this was a mistake
made by the mother
the mother brainwashed this kid into
doing this and now she's going to keep
that brainwash going brainwashing going
so he may never fully come to terms of
what happened to him at least as long as
his disgusting wretch of a mother is
still alive
so something to always keep in mind
that'll do it for this portion of shows
move over to the members block if you're
not a member yet you can become a member
and use code wall should check out for
two months free on all annual plans hope
to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]